Marjorie Taylor green used the death
count from the hijacked 911 Flight 93 to
minimize the risk of shooting down the
Chinese spy balloon Overland and The
Crowd Goes completely silent you have to
see this this is stunning stunning stuff
Marjorie Taylor green and a bunch of
right Wingers initially went after Joe
Biden by saying he's not going to have
the testicular fortitude that's my word
not theirs to shoot down the Chinese
surveillance balloon
As We Know Joe Biden eventually shot
down the Chinese surveillance balloon
and so Republicans had to shift their
tone shift their message some of them
shifted to who cares any president would
have done it but Marjorie Taylor green
is Shifting to he didn't need to wait
for the balloon to go over water before
shooting it down that was a move
he should have shot it down over land
and as proof as to how benign that is
think back to 9 11. remember when there
was that crash I mean even describing it
as a crash when there was that crash
nobody I mean yes everybody on the plane
died but nobody on the ground died it is
so quiet as Marjorie Taylor green says
these disgusting things in this room the
crowd was all jazzed up up until this
point it goes so quiet that if somebody
dropped a pin you would be able to hear
it take a look at this and then finally
leaves the coast and then oh they shot
it down
the excuses that were given on this were
pathetic absolutely pathetic they told
us it was too risky oh it was too risky
to shoot down the Chinese Bible and do
you know what a bunch of that
is
they said it's three school buses three
school buses wide okay well do you guys
remember on 9 11 when an airplane
crashed in Pennsylvania
a jetliner remember that oof it didn't
kill anybody on the ground killed
everyone on board but it didn't kill
silence instantly silenced anyone on the
ground so they want to tell all of us
that it was too risky to take down that
Chinese Bible in over rural Idaho or
Montana or any of these other states or
Alaska anyway quite a bold analogy to be
making but in the service of attacking
any decision made by Joe Biden anything
is fair game for people like Marjorie
Taylor green a disgusting person
usually I say a disgusting woman and
someone wrote to me and said David sir
might you be a misogynist because if a
man does something disgusting you say
what a disgusting person
but when Marjorie Taylor green does
something disgusting you say what a
disgusting woman
I don't know should I say disgusting
person she's definitely both as far as
we all know she's a woman uh in the in
the in the Valiant battle against trans
wokeests Marjorie Taylor green has drawn
that Line in the Sand she is a woman
should I say she's a disgusting person
or a disgusting woman let me know but
disgusting certainly fits the bill
absolutely no tragedy she is unwilling
to use to her perceived Advantage we
will have all of these clips on our
YouTube channel youtube.com the
davidpackman show and we will also have
these clips in Spanish now on the
Spanish YouTube channel
youtube.com slash at symbol
David packman
espanol I know you're it's like isn't it
espanol but you can't in a URL have the
thing over the end so it's David Pacman
espanol for the Spanish channel it's
crazy I know but check it out email
Services by big tech companies scan
every single email you send and receive
emails from your doctor your spouse
that's why you get those creepy ads a
few minutes later and other companies
collect your data every time you open an
email from them it's a huge mess all of
this information gets sold around they
can piece together where you've been who
you know what you like and it's out
there forever that's why I recommend
start mail start mail never collect data
from your emails it blocks The Trackers
embedded in the emails that you receive
start mail lets you encrypt any email
you send even if the recipient doesn't
use encryption keeping your messages
safe from prying eyes start mail never
shows you ads and unlike other services
when you delete an email it's gone
forever and I love this part you can
create unlimited email aliases so you
don't have to give companies your real
email address which can really really
cut down on spam you can seamlessly
migrate your emails and contacts from
Gmail Outlook Yahoo and others it's
really easy start taking your privacy
seriously by signing up for start mail
you'll get 50 off your first Year's
subscription go to startmail.com Pacman
the link is down below